[Music]
who you for you Russia how are you guys
okay
what the hell
you know Spencer this is Jumanji you
pick a character and then you're that
person in the game should we play
[Applause]
my god fridge yum fridge who are you
me Spencer Martha yeah
I think we got sucked into the game and
we've all become the avatars we chose so
that means Bethany I'm an overweight
middle-aged man this can't actually be
happening guys how are we gonna get home
this is a video game which means we all
have special skills
[Music]
strengths villas speed smoldering
intensity damn that is a man right there
I hate this game
if we don't want to get stuck in Jumanji
we have to help each other maybe we're
all in a coma what metal game machine
get in there go safer I'm not getting in
there are you ok I'm still an old fat
guy right I'm afraid so I have to warn
you I think I'm a very strong puncher
[Music]
what is it
don't let this new body get your butt
whooped I'd like to see you try
[Music]
I found something you gotta check this
out you please for games anymore
yo what's this
[Applause]
Jumanji pick a character and you're that
person in the game Bethany you went and
I'll spend my life staring at a TV
screen
it's my hair
where's rest of me
oh my god we're in different people's
party
Stephanie don't look at it I'm an
overweight middle-aged man wait a second
where's my phone
don't cry don't cry don't cry don't go I
think we become the avatars we challenge
welcome to to lungi this is a video game
which means we each have three lives
let's go I'm Alex watch your step in
here so gnarly we can help each other we
all have special skills weakness I hate
this game everybody else got good stuff
weakness Hey
yes cake is my weakness look at what is
valet what is that I think it means you
carry my weapon - give them to me when I
tell you to don't let this new body get
your butt wolf we have to work together
I think it's a staring contest who's
good at staring and not blinking Edison
I'm amazing at it
[Music]
I like can't even with this place
we gotta go get on my back
no no I'll carry you come on I would
rather die get on my back no I'm going
down
[Music]
biggest pound cake cake isn't that your
weakness something happening to me come
on my shaking I'm just still black yes
okay fine everything is fine it's all
good
[Applause]
fun group welcome to detention Spencer
Bethany fridge Martha you're all here
for a reason you know what it is you
should be thinking about who you are and
who you want to be fortunately you'll
have plenty of time to figure that out
while you're cleaning out the basement
that yo Spencer is this Jumanji a game
for those who seek to find a way to
leave their world behind we're those
avatar names so you pick a character and
then you're that person in the game swim
to a boot I don't think it matters how
much should we play
[Music]
hey where the rest of me my god
bridge yam fridge who are you it's me
Spencer who is she
think we got sucked into the game and
we've all become the avatars we chose so
that means I'm Bethany Bethany Bethany
[Applause]
I'm an overweight middle-aged man
welcome to Jumanji
everybody run
Wow
I have to warn you I think I'm a very
strong puncher
don't cry don't cry don't cry it's gonna
be okay alright alright I can't help
well the fun group welcome to detention
Spencer
definite fridge Martha you're all here
for a reason you should be thinking
about who you are and who you want to be
you'll have plenty of time to figure
that out while you're cleaning out the
basement are you gonna help
are you too pretty I'm too pretty yeah
what's this a game for those who seek to
find a way to leave their world behind
Jumanji you pick a character and you're
that person in the game which ones real
quick I don't think it matters that much
juice pinball sounds like a better than
I'll be the curvy genius dr. smolder
brave stop guessing Ruby roundhouse
guys hey where's the rest of me my god
rich yam fries who you me Spencer
[Music]
why are wearing half a shirt and short
shorts in the jungle think we got sucked
into Jumanji and we'd become the avatars
we chose so that means
Bethany Bethany don't look at it I'm an
overweight middle-aged man I don't have
my claritin and all I see around here is
pop well I don't have a top due date of
my body
damn it there's a man right there don't
cry don't cry don't cry it's gonna be
okay
this is a video game which means we all
have special skills
it was so intense I like can't even with
this place
[Music]
what not old game machine muscle like
you
get in there savor I don't not gonna get
in there you get in there yeah I got a
backpack oh you don't get water with it
backpack everybody knows that
you